blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
pakman the uh trump writer known in the
media as the q anon shaman has been
sentenced to 41 months in prison and
we're going to talk about the sentence
we're going to talk about consequences
in general the way that these court
cases are going and really what the
philosophy or approach should be in
terms of sentencing for these
individuals now to step back for a
second and kind of set the stage
there are hundreds of alleged trump
writers
whose cases are pending right now and
we're starting to see sentences as
sentences that are very mild ranging all
the way up to several years now when we
talk about consequences for the trump
riots
one side of that are the consequences
for individuals that participated people
like the q anon shaman jacob chansley
and others and we're going to talk about
that in a moment there's a whole other
side to consequences which is
consequences for those that instigated
it
those that
created
the environment in which half of the
republican party or more
believed that the election was actually
won by donald trump and that joe biden
stole it in some way and thus
it was in some way justified to go to
washington dc on january 6th and do what
they did
there have been no consequences for
those people whatsoever and that
includes the pres former president
donald trump himself it includes people
around donald trump it includes members
of the house of representatives it
includes members of the senate it's a
very very long list and when we talk
about consequences for them
really we're probably talking about
political consequences i don't think
there's any chance nor arguably even a
legal basis
for charges against someone like
i mean i don't know to pick someone uh
madison kawthorne i don't know you know
the people that were going around uh
fomenting and instigating
um there's a question as to whether
there will be political consequences for
some of those people the answer is also
probably not because most of them are in
very red districts safe districts the
people in the senate many aren't even up
for reelection in 2022 so that's one
side that's not going particularly well
now to the sentences and to the news of
today
we are starting to see sentences stack
up for some of these writers on the i
think it was the monday bonus show we
talked about roughly the same amount of
time about 40 months
for one of the other rioters
one of the most prominent writers is
this guy jacob chansley known as the
kewanon shaman he has now been sentenced
to 41 months the man known as kuanon
shaman who stormed the senate chamber on
january 6th adorned in face paint and
wearing a fur helmet with horns was
sentenced to 41 months behind bars on
wednesday 34 year old jacob chansley
from phoenix arizona pleaded guilty in
september to one felony count
of obstruction for his role in trying to
block the counting of the 2020 electoral
college votes he faced up to 20 years in
prison on the charge federal prosecutors
themselves had only asked for 51 months
that was the longest requested sentence
so far in the trump riots u.s district
judge royce lamberth handed down a
41-month sentence and also three years
probation once released in sentencing
chansley lamberth said he thought
chansley was quote genuine in your
remorse but the severity of the crime
warrants the sentence what you did hear
was horrific as you can now see um q
anon shaman of course as we're showing
you here is this guy whose shirtless
picture wearing the horn fur hat and the
flag and the megaphone and the whole
thing images of this guy went viral very
very quickly
videos showed him inside and outside the
capitol building yelling at police
officers leading a mob eventually
getting into the senate chamber where he
scrawled it's only a matter of time
justice is coming on paper covering the
desk where mike pence had been presiding
minutes earlier
he was in
court yesterday with a beard a green
prison jumpsuit addressed the court
referenced jesus gandhi and the movie
shawshank redemption expressed remorse
and said he would do everything
differently i was wrong for entering the
capital i have no excuse the behavior is
indefensible now chansley asks for a
time served meaning
he gets credit for the time he's already
spent behind bars saying he's not
dangerous he's not violent he's not an
insurrectionist or a domestic terrorist
and he's nothing like the other people
he has been incarcerated with so what
what's the takeaway here right
um first of all there are people who are
annoyed at only 41 months a few things
to note first of all the prosecutors
only ask for 51 months so oftentimes we
see could be 20 years
when prosecutors say given the
circumstances we're only asking for 51
months it's rare not unheard of but rare
that judges sentence people to more than
prosecution asks for number two
he did take a guilty plea and he did
show remorse now we could say the
remorse isn't genuine the judge felt
that it was
but it is um one of these situations
where
if he were
the earlier sentences are increasingly
people who were taking pleas
it would be reasonable to think
that those who are going to push not
guilty
maybe go to trial etc
if they are found guilty we could see
even longer sentences trials take longer
than please all else being equal so we
won't know about those sentences for a
period of time also i got a couple
emails from people saying why wasn't
this guy charged with treason
um
that is very very difficult and
typically prosecutors are not going to
do that
unless they are
very confident in the evidence and uh
state of mind is a factor there same
same with something like sedition so
that that's just really tough it's not
surprising that the q anon shaman was
not charged with treason now the fox
news perspective on this at least the
perspective of fox news contributor will
kane is that the q anon shaman was
brainwashed i guess by the left while he
was in custody insidious part tucker he
was submitted to and he did submit to
some type of brainwashing i mean they
have made all of these january 6th
defendants essentially repent from any
beliefs they ever had and echo critical
race theory ideas read the right books
and tell a judge they apologize for
everyone and everything they've ever
been it's it's really gross and it's a
violation of due process and it's just a
violation of our sense of justice now i
don't know if the references to gandhi
or whatever were part of that i'm not
really sure
but that's what we might call an
alternative perspective and that's
actually something that's being repeated
a lot by the right which is these
uh
alleged insurrectionists are not only
being treated unfairly some of them by
being kept detained in pre-trial
detention they're not allowed out on
bail or they can't afford it um they're
also being brainwashed
as the cases against them are going
forward okay um so
overall the prison sentences are getting
longer and longer in the last week we
saw the two longest prison sentences of
above 40 months the lesser charges for
the trump rioters are kind of being
moved out of the way first
and um i expect that some of these are
going to get longer and longer over time
one thing that is curious is why aren't
trump supporters angry
that the rioters are sort of being left
out to dry
they did the thing that they believed
trump wanted them to do
they showed up they tried to interfere
with the count they tried to prevent joe
biden from becoming president they did
the thing that trump thought was right
remember trump in the video on january 6
said it's time to go home but i get why
you're here makes sense that you're here
you're doing a beautiful thing we love
you i believe he said
um
but now they're just kind of being left
out to dry why aren't they all furious
with trump about that i don't know just
a question
i want to talk briefly about something
going on in poland now i've mentioned
before
there are a number of epicenters of
nationalism of different kinds as well
as anti-semitism which often go very
much together in europe
poland sadly is one of those places and
um i want to tell you about what's been
going on there
death to jews was being chanted by
polish nationalists at a rally
during which they were burning books
about jews in poland
this is 2021
polish nationalists shouted death to
jews as they burned a book representing
a historic pact protecting the rights of
poland's jews the book burning at a
rally in kalas a city of about a hundred
thousand 120 miles southwest of warsaw
was part of a series of national
nationalist events
last week
national independence day which is the
anniversary of when poland regained
sovereignty in 1918.
videos and eyewitness accounts on social
media show a far-right activist whose
name i'm not even going to try to
pronounce
lit a red red covered book meant to
symbolize the statue of khalas the
document issued in 1264 by prince
bolaslaw the pious regulated the legal
status of jews living in poland and
afforded some protection through
penalizing attacks on them the statue
served as the legal foundation for
relations between non-jews and jews in
poland
this guy poured a flammable liquid on
the book and lit it on fire the crowd
was chanting death to jews
some chanted no to poland
yes to poland poland is both the hebrew
language name for poland and the name of
the main jewish museum in warsaw
police are studying the footage studying
the footage and the eu coordinator for
fighting anti-semitism katarina von
schnerbain
wrote on twitter these pictures send
shivers down the spine
other large nationalist events also
taking place in poland you know it's
really it's really sad to me what's
going on in poland as i i think
mentioned before
my family
um
jews from eastern europe coming from
really two main places ukraine on my
dad's side
and poland and romania on my mom's side
my grandfather was actually born in
poland
fled poland uh when he was five in 1929
to argentina
and uh poland is a place where
the jewish population was quite
literally decimated or more
through world war ii and it is still a
place where there is disgusting
hostility open hostility to jews i
there's this crazy story i may have told
before a few years ago when my dad had a
conference in poland
he was walking around some i forget what
city it was in but there were some um
sort of notable
homes in which i think it was like jews
were hidden during the holocaust or
something like that you know notable
notable places and it's a place where
tour groups go
and there was a group of college
students doing a survey
of folks who were there
and they said to my dad do you want can
we can we interview you for the survey
my dad says sure
and one of the questions is
how much would you be bothered
if jews moved in next door to you and
the options were a little bit
a moderate amount
a lot and i would move out because it
would bother me so much and my dad
pointed out you know with the language
barrier to some degree that existed
there everybody trying to speak english
why isn't it an option that i might not
be bothered at all
at all by jews moving in next to me it's
sort of a strange absence of an option
and it sort of struck the interviewers
as like oh yeah
maybe we maybe that should be an option
it didn't even occur to us that maybe
that's a reasonable option so even like
this is an example of how
this was not presumably an overtly
anti-semitic study that was being done
but the absence of i wouldn't be
bothered if jews moved in next door was
very strange and there's kind of this
underlying thing that that's still there
entrenched in some way um in parts of
poland so that's what's going on in
poland we've been covering the rise of
nationalism in europe and different
countries and uh very very scary stuff
you can find me on twitter at deepakman
we're going to take a quick break and be
right back after this
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded try blinkist for free and
get 25 off a subscription go to
blinkist.com
david pakman the link is down below
you can find the david pakman show
subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t
there are now more than 33 000 of our
viewers and listeners who are subscribed
there for free you can post your
thoughts about any of the stories we
talk about stories you want me to talk
about or anything else that's on your
mind a few interesting posts that i
spotted this morning um user
pumpkin pie says when it comes to
messaging the right has a lot more
upside from the written house trial than
the left no matter the outcome i know
this probably isn't a popular view on a
left-leaning subreddit just hear me out
i don't think it's smart for the left to
put all their chips on the written house
case agreed if britton house is found
innocent well remember it would be not
guilty the right gets to take a victory
lap meanwhile the left left is stuck
with complaining about how unfair the
world is i'm already cringing at the
meltdowns we're gonna see if rittenhouse
is found guilty the right gets a new
martyr going into the midterms the left
has to admit the system worked which
undermines their argument about how
broken the justice system is
and ultimately seems self-contradicting
what are your thoughts i agree 100 i've
been talking about this for a long time
uh either way either way the right wins
on the written house uh trial they will
either make him a hero or they will make
him a martyr and the hero lionization
has already started i played for you the
interview that wendy written house kyle
rittenhouse's mom did with sean hannity
on fox news late last week and it was
all about kyle is the victim and he's so
great and the media is bad and the
prosecutors are bad and democrats are
bad everybody's just bad bad bad and
unfair
and um if uh
we're gonna come to a fork in the road
with the verdict which could be hours
away could be days away we don't know
the jury is deliberating as we are
filming today
um if if if it's all not guilty it is
considered a vindication of what kyle
rittenhouse did
it will also embolden vigilantism the
idea that you can bring a gun into a
situation that uh is a as an optional
situation
create a situation in which you feel uh
threatened for your life
uh shoot people in self-defense in the
case of joseph rosenbaum uh four times
uh not three not not once uh even though
the first shot was disabling by
everything we know
um and then be found not guilty so it
will encourage vigilantism it's going to
be that's going to be if it's all not
guilty
um if it's all guilty it will be
a biased trial
that never should have been filed
this kid's being made an example out of
and he's the victim and whatever time he
serves in prison will be considered his
penance as the martyr that he will be
made now there's also a completely
plausible situation where you get a mix
of things you get not guilty on the
major charges as written but maybe
guilty of some lesser included charges
or may be guilty on one of the minor
charges and not guilty on the major
charges and then it's just going to be a
propaganda war but needless to say
the left has very
little
to gain from either outcome justice
aside whatever you believe to be justice
aside
and the right is going to be using this
kid as either a hero or a martyr uh for
the foreseeable future very very
accurate statement
um another post i want to highlight from
reflex point is what happened to the
hatred mail segment those were hilarious
with the voice actor did haters stop
sending david emails someone posted that
there were legal reasons for why we
stopped it there's no legal reasons why
we stopped hatred mail but i've told the
story before and i'll tell it again
um
when we stopped doing hatred mail it was
sort of in the heat of the 2020 election
i and we were receiving
way more death threats than ever
we were receiving
things in the mail that were more
concerning than ever
and in speaking with my contacts at the
fbi
and other law enforcement agencies and
kind of just go and our security
consultant quite frankly um
and going over the totality of
everything they felt listen at least for
now
the hatred mail thing is generating a
lot of noise relative to the signal
and it's going to make it harder
to more seriously take
to discern
the real threats that need to be looked
into
and so it wasn't a legal recommendation
it was really more of a security
recommendation and hatred mail guy
completely understood and this was a
time when as i've mentioned before
fbi has shown up at the houses of people
that have sent us threats to talk to
them and evaluate whether they presented
a bona bonafide bonafide threats and so
we made the decision because things have
so escalated and the number of threats
was so high that we want to do anything
we can not to encourage more potential
noise
and allow us to discern the signal will
it ever come back maybe maybe we're
going to look into that uh but we
decided to cancel it out because of the
craziness of the 2020 election this also
relates to as many of you know we have
we have a second studio
and a lot of other things that are going
on okay so it's all related to that i
think i i will leave it there join the
discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit
you know when the fbi does a raid
um they already probably have a pretty
good case
and a pretty substantive suspicion
about wrongdoing that has taken place
the fbi has raided the home
of radical republican congresswoman
lauren bobert's ex-campaign manager
this is not
a good sign for lauren lauren bober
um let's read this article from salon by
igor darish the fbi on tuesday raided
the home of a colorado election clerk
and three others in an investigation
uh-oh
into a voting system security breach
mesa county clerk tina peters a
republican was accused by state
officials in august of helping to leak
voting system passwords to a right-wing
blog i thought the left was doing the
voter fraud peters later appeared at my
pillow ceo mike lindell's conspiracy
laden laden cyber symposium or sibosium
as mike pillow refers to it where the
pillow magnate promised but failed to
produce evidence of election rigging
peters later briefly went into hiding
with lindell's help amid fbi scrutiny we
covered that when it happened you might
remember i we did the story mike pillow
is helping to hide
um an official
accused of uh tampering so that that's
this individual
on tuesday morning the fbi and local
prosecutors raided peter's home we
executed four federally court authorized
operations today to gather evidence in
connection with the investigation
we did so with assistance from the da's
office from the 21st judicial district
the attorney general's office and the
fbi said district attorney dan
rubinstein
yes dan rubenstein and yes there are
already anti-semitic comments on the the
fact that this took place if you find
that if you look online at the comments
not encouraging you to do it but you can
peters is on uh is an interview in an
interview on lindell's online streaming
channel said the raid left her quote
terrified
the fbi also raided a home in garfield
county
lindell said one of the homes raided
belongs to sharona bishop a garfield
county resident who served as lauren
bobert's campaign manager bishop has
been one of peter's most prominent
allies in stoking unfounded allegations
of voting machine problems in the
election and hinted at a rally last
month that she was privy to unreleased
data from mesa county
um
this is every every element of this is
absolutely crazy
uh the fbi raided my home as of 6 am
this morning accusing me of committing a
crime they raided the homes of my
friends mostly older women i was
terrified they used a battering ram to
destroy one of her friend's front doors
they took all my electronics they were
soldiers in combat gear not men in suits
with badges they looked like they were
in a combat zone
uh man you know the same it's so funny
because we've been against no knock
warrants for so long
um for not particu
obviously for non-violent offenses and
then beyond that we can have a
conversation these folks have been for
no knock warrants forever and now all of
a sudden they're saying they're coming
in like it's a war zone yes that's what
we've been saying all along
and the allegations in this entire
fiasco are pretty wild
they include that the elections clerk
gave out passwords to their systems uh
deliberately ran from the fbi with the
help of mike pillow helping to hide them
but we're supposed to believe it's the
democrats that committed the election
fraud given that this is what's going on
it's crazy it is absolutely crazy and
they probably have something very
serious here and whether it will hit
lauren beaubert we just don't know yet
but it very well may
remember when we talk about the fbi in
recent years raiding people
from the republican party we are aware
of folks who shared internal campaign
materials with russia
we have folks associated with trump who
were subsequently indicted for tax
evasion bank fraud remember michael
cohen uh some of the folks who remained
friendly with donald trump ultimately
received pardons for the things they
were convicted of but when the fbi
starts starts the raids it's not looking
particularly good
fbi agents don't tend to go after
political staffers ex-campaign managers
etc unless they have a really serious
case already remember when they some of
you might remember this you may not
there was that congressman jefferson
who uh whose office and uh home were
raided and there were bricks of cash in
the freezer and the fbi already knew
exactly what they were looking for at
the point that the raids start they
already have a lot of information and
that seems to be exactly what is going
on here so
do you believe it will eventually hit
lauren beaubert i guess is the main
question i have for you right now let me
know your thoughts and we're going to
have more coverage of this on our
instagram which you can find at david
pakman show we also maybe tomorrow maybe
monday we'll be announcing the next
viewer town hall the one we did in
october
went wild extremely popular event where
everybody gets to call in and of course
members get priority
we'll be announcing the next one for
early december tomorrow or monday so
stay tuned for that we're going to take
a quick break and be right back
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
it's a great pleasure today to be
speaking with jeffrey west who's a
theoretical physicist and professor at
the santa fe institute
one of his uh great
books which i recently read is scale the
universal laws of growth innovation
sustainability and the pace of life
in organisms cities economies and
companies uh professor west it's so
great having you on
hey david thank you for inviting me
pleasure to be home so
i want to start with something very
basic just to kind of get the audience
acquainted with with the subject matter
of the book when we talk about scale
in life
we can apply this to
the human body we can apply this
across
species we can look at businesses cities
etc as you do
how did you first come into being
interested in this concept of scale in
life
well i think really it originates you
know i'm a theoretical physicist
in terms of my training and my career
dealing with fundamental questions in
physics you know quarks and gluons and
string theory and evolution of the
universe etc um you know those big
questions but in that um a major theme
in that and in fact across physics and
all engineering and technology is the
question of scale how do you scale up
what happens if you scale up a body if
you scale up a building um if you scale
up the universe uh you know what you
know these some of these might be
hypothetical questions uh but some of
them are uh you know very seriously
practical questions that we have to face
in society so so i got interested from
fundamental physics but uh realizing um
and that that was sort of the the thing
later in my career that this had
implications just as you said across the
entire spectrum of the world around us
in the book you give examples of aspects
of life that scale linearly sublinearly
or super linearly and this gives rise to
certain efficiencies and inefficiencies
that we can identify
a number we couldn't possibly talk about
every interesting anecdote that you
include in the book but again to give
the audience some idea of what we're
talking about could you give us one
example of each of these three phenomena
in life that can be observed
sure yes so the simplest is linear
linear simply means if i double the size
of the system
i get something twice as big that's
simply so for example
if you double the size of a city not
surprisingly
you sort of get twice as many
dwellings let's call it that way twice
as many houses because each person so to
speak needs a place to live so that's
linear so that's not surprising
but um
the
sublinear what we call sublinear is when
if you double the size you don't get
twice as much but you get less than
twice as much so for example
to take a different system
at mammals we're a mammal
and we go from a shroom to a mouse
to us to elephants and blue whales and
what is amazing is if you look at any
quantity that describes them any
physiological variable like the number
of heartbeats the length of the aorta
how long they live these scale in a very
regular systematic way and one of the
most fundamental quantities is metabolic
rate how much food you need each day to
stay alive and if you double the size of
an organism or you looked at one that's
twice the size of another you might have
naively expected well you need twice as
much food you have twice as many cells
no you actually need roughly speaking
three quarters as much you save 25
with each saving that's called
sub-linear scaling and is a
manifestation of a systematic economy of
scale so before you give us an example
of super linear
to think about that example
you could in a sense have a uh an
individual that weighs twice as much as
another they don't need twice the food
they only need 75 more it's more
efficient on a per pound basis in that
sense yes the south well
what i would like to talk about here is
less about those within species than
across species
discuss scaling we can also discuss
scaling within it's slightly different
sure but if you just look at just across
species across different mammals then
there's this savings so put slightly
differently um each cell in your body
if you double the size actually requires
less energy the bigger you are and by
the way that feeds into why it is that
bigger animals live much longer than uh
smaller ones because they're using less
energy to support the same gram of
tissue or the same cell
so it's a systematic economy of scale
and by the way we see that in our cities
it's the same thing in terms of our
infrastructure you double the size of a
city i said you need twice as many
houses but you only need about 85
percent as many roads or 85 as much
electrical lines so it's quite similar
to biology except the saving is sort of
15
with each doubling rather than 25
but it's again an economy of scale
sub-linear scaling
now an example of of super linear
scaling
yeah so super linear scaling is quite
fascinating because it really does not
occur in the natural biosphere
it's almost all sublinear scaling and
the biosphere is incredibly efficient
it's uh this economy of scale permeates
um on the other hand but social systems
socioeconomic systems have the opposite
behavior and that comes about because
socioeconomic
systems are driven by
social networks interaction between
people like you and i are doing and we
build on each other in terms of the
conversation and that means the bigger
you are and so i mean the less per
capita so to speak you have the more per
capita so the example would be for
example if you ask how many patents how
many ideas are created in a city and
look at it as a function of the size of
a city so again totally naively if you
double the size of the city that means
you have twice as many people well you
might get twice as many patents no
you actually get
another 15 added every time you double
so the bigger the city the more ideas
are created and that's because they're
more social interactions and so on
and the more of all social economic
activity the higher the wages per capita
and so on and so forth so we would
expect
we would expect that in a one million
person city
there would be more patents than in the
sum total of ten hundred thousand person
cities exactly that's a very nice way of
saying it and the way we often say it is
like that i think that's it's a very
powerful way of saying you you gain
tremendously by bringing people together
rather than divvying them up
into groups subgroups which act
autonomously and of course you gain
something very big i mean that's nothing
to do with quality of life for example
but in terms of sort of material
kinds of metrics
bigger is better
in the book a fascinating um example of
this that you give
is you compare for example a very very
small animal like a mouse
to an elephant and you say well the
elephant lives a lot longer in terms of
time the elephant also has a much slower
heartbeat
and so over the course of the life of a
mouse and an elephant even though the
elephant is here for many more years its
heart beats more slowly and both the
mouse and the elephant would have
roughly the same number of heartbeats
per lifetime
that that's quite fascinating
what what is the underlying principle
that is guiding that
yes no it's it's it is it's quite
fascinating
that uh the number of heartbeats in a
life span if you look across all mammals
from the smallest to the largest is
roughly the same about one and a half
billion
and um
and what is underlying that and all of
the scaling laws is networks it's the
fact that all these things are
controlled by networks and all the work
that i did was in terms of
deriving
the
the concepts and the mathematics
that
show you where these scaling laws come
from and in particular where this
scaling law this invariant so to speak
this
this constancy of heartbeats comes from
and indeed just let me just go back to
something i said earlier uh just to give
you a sense of that is that um
the uh i said that the bigger you are
the the the less energy needed per cell
to stay alive so your
your cells are working um less hard than
your cats or dogs but they're working
harder than your elephants
so to speak and so the bigger you are
the less hard the cells work therefore
less damage is done within the cell and
in transporting energy and information
through these networks
therefore you can live longer because
you're doing less damage so that's sort
of the
the the the the sort of simple idea
behind it you live longer if you're
bigger because you do less damage
transporting energy information and
resources to the cells to keep you alive
and uh so that causes the decrease and
the and in fact all
rates basically
slow down the bigger you are in a
systematic way so that if you look
through the right lens
it's not just that life life spans are
the same so to speak that is you should
measure them by heartbeats but your
growth rates and everything else
is sort of the same if you you they all
rescale to look quite similar if you
rescale accordingly so it brings up sort
of a speculative question even though um
a mouse lives two years
and uh a whale is 125 years maybe in a
certain sense experientially
it's the same
right all processes have rescaled
appropriately yeah this is often brought
up when people talk about their dogs
quite frankly where they say
we experience the dog's life as being
relatively short compared to ours
but if we account for all of these
systems you're talking about
the dog may experience a life that to it
feels just as long as ours we just don't
know
we don't know of course as i say it's
speculative yeah by the way i want to
add one major caveat to that yeah
we are one of those mammals
and indeed if you look at us as sort of
biologically biologically meaning when
we were hunter-gatherers before we
discovered language
social networks
innovation and created all the marvelous
things that we do now
um when we were purely biological we fit
perfectly on all these scaling cards we
had the right metabolic rate uh we lived
30 or 40 years now some of your
listeners may have already realized that
one and a half billion heartbeats
corresponds for a human being to about
uh 30 or 40 years which of course was
the lifespan of human beings
on the average until
maybe only a hundred years ago you know
you my great-great-grandfather
his life expectancy was about 45 and
that was typical in and i come from
england in the united kingdom it was
also typical in the united states so
then we violated that so we have
completely violated the scaling law in
terms of our metabolism we now even
though biologically we only use 2 000
food calories a day but in fact the
amount of energy we need to have this
kind of standard and quality of life is
more like a hundred times that so all of
our metrics get distorted and we've
separated ourselves from the this
marvelous unity
and integration of nature
let's let's dig into exactly that topic
because there's so many different
aspects of what you talk about that that
are relevant to this idea of human
longevity
first i guess to kind of establish a
level playing field
is it not true that even when the
average life expectancy at birth was 40
or 45 that that was significantly
influenced by high infant mortality and
that if one made it to say age 20 their
odds of becoming much older are were
actually quite similar to what they are
today is is that not a factor
yeah it's roughly true um it's still
nevertheless true that uh so let me give
you some statistics in about 1830 the
lifespan of a human being on the planet
was about 35 maybe
in
what became developed countries that
number was more like 45 40 early 40s
but it increased if you took out infant
mortality if you just remove those that
died before age one because in the
natural state you know we're supposed to
have you know 10 to 12 children and
three or four supposed to die i hate to
put it so crassly um
and um and so if you take out those that
died in in in infancy and the number
does increase to 40 45 and then but then
just as you say if you make it
beyond um i forget the age exactly but
if you make it sort of age 10 12 and so
on into your through your teens uh your
likelihood of reaching 60
is now
not as high as it is now that's for sure
but is already significantly increased
and indeed people did live i mean there
were we obviously know historically
people who lived to 60 80 even 100
obviously but they were outliers and um
a long tail in the distribution of ages
so and and the the biggest change by the
way that took place in increasing
longevity took place in the 19th century
with the uh introduction of um access to
clean water right and
hygiene hygiene and sewer putting in
sewers and so on had has had the biggest
increase in our longevity uh because up
to then uh the overwhelming majority of
people did not wash themselves obviously
didn't have access to hygiene we're
going to pause our interview with
professor jeffrey west there we will
post the full interview to our youtube
channel don't miss it absolutely
fascinating uh the youtube channel of
course
the
youtube.com
pakman show
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com
davidpakmanshow where you can get access
to behind the scenes videos the daily
bonus show the commercial free daily
show as well as special discounts on
merch including hats hoodies mugs and
t-shirts you can support the show for as
little as two dollars a month check it
out at patreon.com davidpakmanshow you
know i've been really hopeful that i was
never again going to have to mention the
name sherry10penny to you it's a
horrible name not on principle but
because of who sherry 10 penny is you
may or may not remember that sherry 10
penny is this anti-vaccine
osteopathic physician
who believes that vaccines cause autism
who previously made all sorts of wild
statements about kovid and about
vaccination
she is back and she is now saying that
vaccinating children which is the next
phase of getting out of this pandemic
we gotta get everybody vaccinated or as
close to everybody as possible we now
can vaccinate five to eleven year olds
with the pfizer vaccine dr tenpenny dr
tenpenny is back saying that's like a
late term abortion if you give a vaccine
to a kid it's like a really really
really late term abortion now as a
reminder
this is from a few months ago
here is sherry tenpenny
saying that we really shouldn't be
afraid of covid
but she is spreading all sorts of
horrible lies about the vaccines to make
people afraid remember this this was
months ago take a look
thinking if there is a if you can think
of any other product in any other
industry that has killed more than five
thousand people stated in the verse
database and even if only half of those
are true
two hundred twenty five hundred deaths
in six months of use and it's still full
court press full steam ahead so it makes
one have to wonder why
why are we still doing this why are we
putting people into nursing homes like
that happened in new york and put people
with with known covet into place yeah um
10 penny also promotes conspiracies
about 5g cell phone networks and more
let's take a listen to that
and
some of the information that i think had
been discussed on your podcast related
to emf frequencies that was a thought
and it was because now because right now
we're all kind of hypothesizing i mean
what is it that's actually being
transmitted that's causing all of these
things is it a combination of the
protein which now we're finding has a
metal attached to it i'm sure you've
seen the pictures all over the internet
of people who've had these shots and now
they're magnetized and put a key on
their forehead it sticks they can put
spoons and forks all over them and they
can stick because now we think that
there's a metal piece to that there's
been people who've long suspected that
there was some sort of an interface yet
to be defined an interface between
what's being injected in these shots and
all of the 5g towers
not proven yet but we're trying to
figure out what is it that's being
transmitted to these unvaccinated people
so this is someone who has made now
i don't know about a career
but she's made herself quite prominent
as a as a sort of a darling of the
anti-vaccine and conspiracy movement
she's been against masks even though we
have scientific
peer-reviewed
studies
about the effectiveness of masks she's
against vaccines she says the vaccines
can kill you they can cause autoimmune
disease that some people will die from
the vaccine directly and others are just
going to get really really sick and get
long-term diseases maybe 42 days out
maybe a year out etc on and on and on
sperm quality
claims etc
so now she has resurfaced at this we
how many people that we have covered
ended up at this very place the reawaken
america rally over the weekend in san
antonio
um michael flynn was there
uh i think mike pillow was there
just so many people that we follow
were at this absolutely horrible event
right-wing pastor john hagee
did the event at the cornerstone church
in san antonio texas here is 10 penny
saying a lot of crazy things dangerous
things including that giving a kid a
vaccine is like an abortion people have
got to start saying to their bosses who
are requiring them to get tested if they
don't get a shot that you need to start
saying to them torture is illegal in the
united states of america now that will
not work the advice that 10 penny gives
will not work vaccine requirements are
legal a vaccine isn't torture you will
probably lose your job if you follow 10
pennies advice
and you repeatedly testing me for being
non-compliant and disobedient is torture
covid tests are not torture either
you're going to lose your job if you do
what she says i think that we're going
to be writing that up and we're going to
sending it into the eeoc and we're going
to start accusing you and these policies
of being torture now the eeoc is the
equal employment opportunity council i
think i think it's that anyway the idea
that if you write to them and say it's
torture to test an employee that the
eeoc is going to get involved it's a
waste of time everything she says is a
waste of time call a spade a spade
and we know that this is murder by
injection right and you're supposed to
give this as sacrificing your children
to
balak
child sacrifice so now
as if it wasn't off the rails before
now they bring in all of this mark of
the beast child sacrifice weird
scriptural stuff being researched in
these final days from the babylonian
mystery schools
wait a second i thought she was here as
a as an osteopathic doctor
what does ba'al have to do with that our
babel in the descendants of nimrod
and this is what is happening and if you
see anybody participating in this you
need to be challenging them
of what they are doing to their
spirituality and what they are
sacrificing their children too you know
i had a really good friend who said you
know we've sacrificed over 60 million
newborn unborn babies in abortion we
have multiple states in this country who
actually allow late term abortion
now we are doing very very very very
late term abortion by killing
five-year-olds so she is saying you give
a five-year-old a vaccine
they're gonna die
it's like an abortion
this is happening in america people
and it's your job
to stop everybody you know and wake them
up and shove it in their face and if
they defund you off of social media who
cares if they defund you off of social
media
this is is this a grifter or is it a
sick woman or is it both
now it's about trying to save unborn
babies and pregnant women it's about the
they now are actually starting a trial
and to give these shots to
six-month-olds
this is child sacrifice this is the
resurgence of child sacrifice from the
days of of the babylonian mystery
schools as it said in genesis 6 genesis
jesus himself said that in those final
days it will be like as in the days of
noah and what were they doing child
sacrifice and what else were they doing
it's funny because you know she's
presented as this great doctor 10 penny
but she flips back and forth between
speaking about her supposed medical
credentials and knowledge
uh which are shaky
versus just making religious claims
where then it's like well so it's just
it's more of like a pastor then it's not
really what what does it really matter
that she's dr 10 penny if what she's
talking about is noah and babylonians
and all and all of these different
things this is a dangerous woman
uh i don't exactly know what licensing
she's subject to it should be
investigated and it should be explored
whether she actually is worthy of that
license but the question i really
continue to come away with is
are we talking about a grifter here or
are we talking about a sick woman
are we talking about a liar are we
talking about someone who's confused
what is it really about i'm curious to
hear from you
i have the most outrageous clip for you
from this judge
bruce schroeder schroeder schrader
everybody tells me a different every
time i pronounce it one way i get an
email saying it's the other one so i'll
say schreider kind of a middle middle
ground on him
in the kyle rittenhouse trial
talking about when he had a black in his
jury
it's you know there's there are things
about this guy that we could say are
relevant to the case substantively that
we are concerned with and there's things
about this guy that just make him seem
kind of like a wacky guy and what this
is about
is the fact that on the day that the
jury started deliberating and as of this
moment the jury continues to deliberate
into day three about the five charges
against kyle rittenhouse the judge you
had a pool of 18 jurors
and they all all watched all of the
testimony and looked at all of the
evidence but only 12 actually
participate in the deliberations so on
the first day of deliberations they had
to choose six of the 18 to serve as
alternates meaning they stay at the
courthouse day after day without
deliberating in case
anything happens to the 12 jurors that
are actually taking part in the
deliberation the way they selected the
six to come out is they had a tumbler
almost like if you had like a lottery
and they tumbled the names pieces of
paper with the juror numbers on them and
they actually had kyle rittenhouse reach
in and select the six people that would
be removed from the uh 18. and a lot of
people in the media thought that was
weird why it's almost like a game show
why is kyle rittenhouse himself doing it
and the judge has a perfectly reasonable
explanation which is
there have been times in the past
where
when it wasn't
when when we were doing it when it was
the clerk for example doing it you would
have an outcome that raised eyebrows
like for example
the
one black potential juror being the one
that is removed and it's like oh my
goodness it looks like racial bias so
the judge explains that in order to
prevent that he says well we'll just let
the defendant do it so that we can't be
accused of hand-picking
juries based on race or any other
features but
he bizarrely in telling the story says
that when they did this once
what came up was a black the black and
it just is so odd to hear him talk this
way take a look at this
it was a big case i think it was a
murder case but i'm not sure
um and there were there was a black
defendant
and there were 13 jurors
one of whom was black
and when the um clerk the clerk the
government official drew the name out of
the tumbler it was a black
the black it was a black
and it was the black only by it
there was nothing wrong with it it was
all okay
but what do they talk about optics
nowadays is that the word for things
that was a bad optic i thought yeah also
bad optics is referring to it was a a
black a black
i think people feel better when they
have control yeah
this is completely reasonable it's what
the substance is completely reasonable
i'm not saying this guy is a racist or
the racist
but the way in which he talks about a
black and the black makes
makes me cringe it really does and this
is just again he's just a very there's
two sides to this guy he seems like a
very quirky strange guy singing songs
during the trial
doing jeopardy questions with people in
the crowd
um
freaking out and yelling at the cameras
about coverage on tele you know all
these just very very strange things and
then there are also the alleged um
biases that are being ascribed to the
judge when it comes to evidence
standards depending on whether the
evidence is presented by the prosecution
or by the defense his evaluation of
different aspects of the trial and
questions to witnesses uh speculative
questions etc okay that's that's a whole
other thing but what a wacky guy
i am very much looking forward to when
this trial is done and we can move on
from it and we are standing by for the
verdict literally as we speak we may be
minutes from the verdict we may be hours
could be days still to go we will see
uh we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 p i want to warn you i am
going to play for you now
what i believe is the most xenophobic
voicemail i've ever received it's about
me the caller is calling it about me
okay
um i'm not going to say anything else
let's listen to it then i will tell you
why i'm highlighting it and i'll tell
you a little more about it
you know what the trouble is with
america pacman is people like you from
south america
that are coming over the border by
millions disease-infected
pigs
that destroyed their own country now
they want to go and destroy my country
instead of worrying about us christians
and the republican party why don't you
do something about stopping all those
sorry son of a [ __ ] coming over or
coming up from south america just like
you you know what i want to see every
one of you run out of this [ __ ]
country you're the sorriest son of a
[ __ ] that have ever been led into
this country if you're really an
american
you would do something about it but i
know where you're from you [ __ ]
cockroach
why am i highlighting this
so of course what this guy says is wrong
you know my my family didn't come over
the border we came with a work visa for
my dad
and green cards and i'm a u.s citizen
um the reason i'm highlighting this is
that it seems lost on this guy
that i came over in the exact same
it we know who this guy is okay we're we
know exactly who this guy is we're
calling him tulsa chris uh he's not
actually from tulsa he's from a
different part of oklahoma we know
exactly who this guy is and we're
calling him tulsa chris just you know
that that's what we're calling him tulsa
chris based on what we know is not
native american and what that means is
that at some point at some point
someone in his family did the exact same
thing that my family did right at some
point someone in his ancestry
came from a different country
and then eventually you had the first
generation of his family that was born
here
but the argument he's making about me i
came here legally as well
um is the exact same argument that at
some point could have been made against
his family
and when we talk about the immigration
situation in the u.s and there's a lot
to talk about daca border overstate
visas work visas uh industries that
depend on documented and undocumented
workers
crime rates among documented immigrants
undocumented immigrants and natural-born
u.s citizens all of these are all issues
we talk about and they're important
issues
but it seems completely missing for some
people like tulsa chris
that
they were in the same position at some
point in time
and you would think that that would get
them to re-examine and say
presumably he doesn't believe his family
was cockroaches that should have been
sent somewhere else maybe it's a racial
thing i don't know maybe european versus
south america i don't know
uh there's there's probably more there
but the hypocrisy
and the ignorance to that reality is
part of what is very very disturbing
about these folks so there there's tulsa
chris with a message of me going back to
where i came from i'm an american
citizen so that i don't think there's
any changing that
um we're going to talk on the bonus show
today about the censure of paul gozar
and some very strange things he did
after being censured for sharing that
video of aoc getting killed in anime
format we're going to talk about a
republican-backed bill to decr
decriminalize marijuana federally and we
will talk about another possibility for
why gas prices are going up all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpackman.com and we will
see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription by going to blinkist.com
david pakman